ennjimi en l'honneur de green zone
nous allons faire une interview chatte
je vous hais
mais il te déteste aussi attention
interview chap
vous êtes prêts yes est ce qu'une chatte
aime être caressé oui combien de bébés
peut avoir une chatte 5
combien de temps dure la relation
sexuelle chez la chatte 20 minutes
non non depuis la 2 minutes ah ouais
ouais
ma chatte ami avec beaucoup plus
longtemps un bon ça les tinner pourquoi
est ce qu'on ne l'avait jamais une
chatte la ninja l'avait donc j'ai pas
avant la chatte se lèchent avec sa
langue humide et rappeuse ouais c'est
bizarre parce que green
enfin quand même lui n'a pas ce qu une
deuxième chance elle rentre enfin les
deux rentrées avec moi dans la salle de
bain bien alors dernière question de
votre interview schatz qui vit comment
reconnaît-on une vieille chatte à la la
moule qui bâille coup
tassili m
je
donc c'est pour vous depuis un an je
vais me rattraper j'espère non il va se
faire après